foreign
welcome to honest trailer commentators
for The DaVinci Code uh a very
historically accurate film that teaches
you all based on real history and the
Bible and everything you need to know
about the Renaissance and Jesus all in
one video
um we uh will be watching the movie
together giving you our behind the
scenes thoughts we also have outtakes
that we cut from this one and we'll be
doing a q a uh so any Da Vinci or Jesus
questions you have throw them in that
chat and we'll respond to them at the
end also we'll tease you with next
week's very very uh enjoyable film
um that also features the Louvre there's
your first it's true yes yes uh for next
week so we're both
but DaVinci one that I just kind of
wanted to revisit because I remember it
being dumb and I was right it uh I I
remember that you when you put in the
chat like hey there's something we can
do and I'm like I absolutely need to
tear this movie apart like I just need
to because I especially now with so many
of the red notices and and this kind of
globetrotting thing you recognize that
there was a time when a movie tried to
take it seriously and then they learned
like I mean I guess not they made a
bunch of sequels but I'm glad that they
haven't decided to go back to that
taking it very seriously thing I would
almost a red notice yeah yeah I would
prefer no I can't say I prefer this is
definitely more interesting than a red
notice but they've made it interesting
in a weird Direction which was like no
banter nope no quips Robert Langdon is
just like I'm just I just along for the
ride I don't want to be here oh God so
much knowledge
cursed we just tell you about these
symbols yeah and he just has to has to
lecture you in every instance so yeah
and the book I remember reading
as a child I don't know when it came out
I was I was way you know kids love New
Testaments well that was like my first
thing that I was into was like Michael
Crichton like right right reading books
like that so Dan Brown was not was a was
a Gateway yeah it was a huge bestseller
if you're a if you're a very young
person who doesn't remember the
mid-ought yeah this was a nationwide and
I think a very fun
premise of like oh there's codes hidden
in Renaissance uh Artistry like that
leads at a mysterious secret from the
Catholic church it's all in the but like
that it's all in the details and the
details of this movie suck it's just
it's a lecture it is a two-hour long
lecture on fake history I don't want to
watch a two-hour long lecture on Real
History that that I think gets to
disagree but yes I think that gets too
much that's a podcast
there's a lot of this movie that just it
feels a little bit more like a film Ted
Talk than a movie and I feel like you
needed to cut down I I know that's what
the book is like and Dan Brown had like
the thing with Dan Brad is he's like
kind of a pretend historian at the same
time as he's a novelist and like he
really was trying to suggest that some
of these ideas are maybe kind of real it
was a little bit like JFK that Oliver
Stone movie where yes you could watch it
just as a fictional movie about this guy
and his ideas yeah but there was also
this idea that on one level Oliver Stone
was saying like no no this is really
what I think happened and I feel like
that that was how Da Vinci Code was
presented and I got I just I don't I'm
not interested in the part where it's
like I'm trying to convince you of the
reality of this just make a just make a
fun movie that's less talk yeah I wonder
if the I feel like this couldn't have
happened this they couldn't have made
this movie today just because they did
it was called Inferno and nobody went to
go right right because I think that like
facts are two facts are too easily
accessible like you only back in the uh
in the 90s what did this come early 2000
this was 06 I think was the movie I
guess the book would have been the early
author right right right where like you
only needed to know more than the
audience you didn't need to really know
a lot about uh the Renaissance or or
biblical biblical reality or whatever
you just needed to sound convincing
enough and nobody would look it up
because like going on Alta Vista what
are you doing yeah no whereas if this
came out today and was the same cultural
phenomenal phenomenal phenomenon that it
was back then there would be 20 Twitter
threads of everything about this that
was wrong and it would be the first
thing you saw when you got on Twitter
you'd be absolutely roasted but uh yeah
I mean when you're reading a book as you
did back then on paperback you weren't
fact checking anything I will say one
other thing that kind of undermines the
case is I think that Dan Brown does this
thing where he's afraid that you're not
gonna get his references like he doesn't
want to delve into a single painting
that that Americans haven't heard of so
every reference we're supposed to
believe these are very high level like
Scholars the most brilliant people in
the world when it comes to early
Christianity the history of the Bible
and yet every reference is like Isaac
Newton or the Holy Grail or the Crusades
like they never reference even like a
battle maybe you haven't heard of or
like and it's like come on that it just
I know that there were more than four
things happened in history if you if
you're like history is six things
Charlemagne in Rome then the Knights
Templar really feels like that and it's
like I think you should have missed it
up make a little bit more esoteric would
have made it feel a lot more real if it
was like maybe a one person you hadn't
heard of and then they get to the
Spanish Inquisition you're like now it's
just a sketch yeah
uh it is I mean Monty Python and the
Holy Grail has a lot more like real
references to actual medieval history
than this does what about the cryptex
that one's real right no no Dan Brown
Dan Brown invented the Crypt that's
incredible that he did that that's not I
he didn't invent the physical Christian
he should have he should have had to
build a real one to put that in the book
all right let's watch the house trailer
for Da Vinci Code
thank you
across the globe in search of adventure
with Harrison Ford you watch Nick Cage
save America then Marky Mark took you to
Papa John's I'm literally in a Papa
John's right now proudly excuse me guys
calling it out doesn't make it okay
on another baffling mystery what's up
with this hair in this wood was that on
purpose is it supposed to be like
professory or The Da Vinci Code
I did no Research into this question why
why is his hair like that this time was
it ever like that again yeah no before
since like Castaway kind of I think
maybe angels and definitely buying I
mean sure when he's not playing Robert
Lane no they never brought this back for
non-langed enrolls okay that's just how
he and Ron Howard pictured I'm doing
some very Robert Langdon thing and
writing in Tom Hanks DaVinci Code hair
why I I did peacock last year I think
it's already pulled off of the peacock
platform but they did a a prequel Series
where it's like a Robert Langdon show
before The Da Vinci Code uh and I I
watched the first episode just to see
did they give the actor the Tom Hanks
movie Hair they did not he looked normal
ah that hair is yeah I think it's
supposed to be that kind of like rakish
Professor like you could see him making
out with like a co-ed or something like
that but it's but it doesn't work
because it's Tom Hanks that's the thing
so thank you uh Scott Weinberg of rotten
tomatoes in 2006 for asking Oh no you're
just reposting someone else who asked um
that's journalism yeah uh Tom Hanks
wanted to look like a scholar so to him
that's scholar hair okay and I wonder
because I've never had a professor or
teacher who had quite that look no no no
um it was supposed to look professory we
were right yeah every time I think
prefer I just think of like every
Professor I ever had who had like gray
locks yeah you know what I mean just
like very like Cornell Westy or like
like that I think of like the salt and
pepper hair you know I think of like a
little Reed Richards I don't necessarily
think of like
48 year old bed head I guess right yeah
that guy Tom Hanks Robert Langdon looks
like he's going to sleep with his grad
students
um and not in a cool way not in the cool
away exactly
keep going
back in 2003 the world Hit the brown
note as Dan Brown plopped out the fakest
story about Da Vinci since Assassin's
Creed II what of the body bring it
inside and put it with the others in a
historical table on the knees like
skimming Wikipedia after six beers with
references to the only three paintings
Americans can name the Mona Lisa the
Vitruvian man just recognize the Last
Supper because they think the only way
you'll care about art history is if they
turn it into an episode of Maury but how
could Christ have a bloodline unless man
he was pregnant at the time of the
crucifixion you are the father
and with the curator of the Louvre gets
shot he'll have just enough time to
write a whole bar trivia night on the
walls
we should get into the
the theology here sadly of The Da Vinci
Code so the what's the group called The
the sex cult that's trying to uh that's
keeping the secret well oh right well I
mean Catholicism wants the secret to
stay hidden or Opus day wants it Opus
day is the conservative group that wants
to destroy the secret uh I forget what
the name of the the keepers is what they
call it yeah whatever Society they want
to Priory of Scion oh boy the priority
mail thank you so they want to prove the
Prius ions yes it just never quite they
resolve they never quite resolve that
tension like they want to show that
Jesus like what if God was one of us
like he's super normal then then who
cares about his bloodline like right if
it's not if he's not magic and he wasn't
the Son of God he was just like a man
well I guess like what what what e
McAllen spoiler alert
what what his whole thing ends up being
is that it's like it's misogyny it's
it's this institutionalized misogyny
because the the Catholic Church in the
Vatican and the early church wanted to
suppress this idea of Jesus not just
having a child with Mary Magdalene but
like leaving them in charge of the
church like I'm you're the you're my
heirs you're going to take over the the
Christian faith when I die and the sort
of the idea was the Vatican was like No
And this alternate fear here where Paul
I think Paul became the leader of the
early church that's what we're trying to
correct so that's why the whole idea of
like you're gonna go to Mary magdalene's
grave and you're going to like kneel to
her and respect her as the real
inheritor of the Christian faith that's
how it was supposed to be like that's
the history we're going to so then why
could she do magic
like it's a great question it's a great
question Daisy Jesus could heal you know
he was he was healer well she tried to
walk on water and she couldn't do that
um basically it looks like she just like
got rid of a dude's panic attacks and
that could just be my therapist does
that and she ain't related to Jesus
right just break out the Temple Run yeah
the Templar rub the way
I think it's it's ambiguous you're
supposed to be like maybe she's just a
comforting person and they're friends or
maybe she has a supernatural Jesus power
got it all right we'll get into the sex
cult stuff too later yeah let's keep
playing that what a weird thing to throw
in anyway
bananagram ranks rocks Madonna up the
rocks
Tom Hanks as Robert Langdon compounding
keywords
zero connection to any of these people
how well did you know the curator not
very well who mostly it just seems
annoyed to be there I've jammed my
shoulder I've been shot at I'm bleeding
but since the most interesting thing
huge over the chance to lecture a whole
new audience to death this is the movie
it's in the lower spatial frequencies
The Horizon is significantly lower on
the left than it is on the right Priory
of Zion is
world's oldest and most secret societies
with leaders like uh Sir Isaac it all
started over a thousand years ago when a
French king conquered the holy city of
Jerusalem this Crusade
templates themselves named for the
original Roseline Roslyn chance the
pairing of those two pyramids it's
Unique the two are geometric Echoes
fascinating pictures says a thousand
words I like genre being our audience
how did they make three of these things
did anyone see the sequels yeah I've
seen it I've seen you saw Inferno yeah
you could tell me anything happens in
Inferno and I believe is it about Dante
it is yeah well done the Dante's Inferno
is the is the sort of the puzzle thing
that he's unlocking but it's basically
there's like uh a plague that's going to
be Unleashed on the whole world and he's
got a ticking clock to like solve the
puzzle to like prevent the plague but
the twist there is he's infected with it
so like he's that so like he's he's
coming in and out of Consciousness and
like he's got amnesia like langdon's all
messed up and Inferno so that's like
he's got to solve the puzzles like he's
like he's got a like it's a high
challenge level because he's got to
solve the puzzles while he's like all
fuzzy that sounds terrible it sounds
like Jurassic world Dominion yeah yeah
where they and then there's locusts I
was gonna say where's the location
there's no Locus but no it is it's it's
it's it's really weird but yes the the
Dante's Inferno is the The Da Vinci of
that one I want to do a da Vinci Code
style mystery but it's only about big
Johnson T-shirts
if you look there it's liquor in the
front and it's an 80s surfware
wait if you look at the Billabong logo
upside down
spells out Harry Magdalene
um all right keep going
oh Amelie and Leon the Professional must
appear in your film Jean Reno is fash
I'm captain bismuth a police officer but
I repeat myself Audrey tattoo is Sophie
the worst descendant of Jesus Christ
according to her grandfathers definitely
not a sex cold
he's not mentioned was that subtext or
text that like she was being groomed by
her grandfather well it is it's text
because they say like he was preparing
her to take over the Priory yeah but but
the sex cult stuff is barely explored at
all it's a single cut away yeah it's
just like wait also we all had sex with
each other anyways I mean I guess that's
as part of that is assumed in like a
like a English boarding school culture I
assume that they're all okay if you're
feeding into the like this is the this
is the sex positive humanistic like this
is the counter Force against the
vaticans misogynist like repressive
regime I guess what you'd think a line
of dialogue exploring that yeah or just
don't show them or just yeah I don't
need to see the exchange of fluids
happen yeah I doubt I can I can Sandra
Bullock that and just be like no
exchange affluence yes because Eyes Wide
Shut for like once back to DaVinci Code
I got distracted I was thinking about
that freaky six way I've already seen
everything
back to the painting
yeah claustrophobic maybe you healed my
phobia with your hands knows how to
handle a whip
no no no you're not gonna make it you're
not gonna make it shut up
and can tolerate men explaining basic
symbols to her even though she's a
police cryptographer it represents
aggression and manhood a simple still
used today in modern military uniforms
the more penises you have the higher
patience of a saint real as everyone
chases each other around some of
Europe's Most dreary tourist traps full
of weird little creeps like Silas Paul
Bettany literally shines as a modern day
Sith Lord with the strength to kill
anyone from a defenseless old nuns
you know I'd probably take something
crazy like a wheelchair-backed guy with
a walking stick to take about
not my body it's my only weakness
I mean just a moment of appreciation for
very memorable stupid felony in Silence
the violence
the head with the stowed tablet because
he really puts it oh he rocked that back
into it like you don't need to hit a nun
that hard in the head with a stone
tablet to kill like it's she's old and
it's big and heavy she was on her way
out but he he like winds up it's like a
it's like a Babe Ruth calling his shot
on the level of Meet Joe Black in terms
of like sudden over the top rounds it's
so big it's so great yeah petney killing
that one way to go betney he's come so
far uh but always like a pale little
weirdo in pretty much every role
yeah this is this is Peak pale little
yeah since they don't get paler more
weird yeah anyways good stuff yeah this
is almost powder keep going
we that uncovers the darkest conspiracy
in the Catholic church in second darkest
that dresses up like an action-packed
Ted talk but plays like Indiana Jones
stripped of anything fun or visually
interesting
a magic cup the souls I've got some
power on Earth
it's nonsense no time to argue throw me
the idol
many of our followers are married many
of them have families only a small
proportion choose to live ascetic lives
you gotta get out of the library I have
to get to a library fast
Story how do you write that line of God
oh God Grail what if God was one of us
Reno 911
oh thank you that's the violist the
butler did it and Doctrine octopus
There's Something About Mary
yeah
yeah the whole movie revolves around
mistaking PS for princess Sophie and I
can't believe How I Met Your Mother
somehow did it better yes
Paul Shaffer Paul Shaffer okay but
imagine if Paul Shaffer was
instead of princesses
hey and Jesus's disciple all right happy
amazing uh one day we'll do How I Met
Your Mother but today yeah hey Paul you
related to uh Jesus yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
Son of God
uh
for watching and please
Anna Jones movie and TV timeline that
Billy put together and Ken knapsock uh
also on this channel it is a wild ride
it turns out Indiana Jones has met
everything he's like you said he's
gumped it he's got his way through
history
um
the young young Indie Chronicles he's
met every major historical figure and
been a part of everything important
that's happened from 1908 to 1993. so uh
yeah go check that out right after this
and if you look up London Grail Pope
Indie company and he's the first one uh
all right now I think we have a few uh
outtakes or at least other names that we
cut let's check that out
starring
Renaissance Man Forest armed Somali the
princess inquiries fast X Bad Teacher
Raising Canes weird albino vision board
Cool Whip undercover Butler and nobody
expects the Spanish Inquisition
night at the museums
A Simple Plan
Leonardo Leeds National Treasure oh God
I didn't see that one again always one
thing right if you went to Harvard you
will find a way to let everyone know
about it for the rest of your life
[Applause]
has never occurred so I didn't realize
that's an auction
close enough all right so let's get into
it I also suggested for the titles it
didn't even make the didn't even make
the short list nobody [__] with the
Jesus
yeah it could be nice for Holby but we
can't we can't curse in the title we
could you could put a little asterisk
there
I think that um something about Mary was
was just perfect uh all right Evan Jay
pretzer is Hanks at the point where his
career has now faded to me it seems like
he's not done anything iconic in a while
wow
great in Asteroid City in theaters right
now oh he's in that wow everyone's a
matter he it's it's it's fascinating
because Wes Anderson has gone on the
record saying despite some of Bill
Murray's recent troubles he's they're
still friends he's going to keep putting
Bill Murray and things but asteroid city
has a role that would clearly normally
be the Bill Murray role yeah but it's
Tom Hanks okay you can make that sub at
this point no I mean and Tom Hanks is
great and and there's apparently no bad
blood between West Anderson and Bill
Murray but uh just a fascinating rink I
mean obviously Pinocchio was not
fantastic
um holy Smoky well he did he did a man
called Otto with Mark Forrester last
year that's like uh having a big moment
on Netflix right now okay I don't know I
I still think it I still think Tom Hanks
he's only ever one movie away from being
everybody's favorite again oh yeah not
burned up all that Goodwill and I think
say what you will about his performance
in Elvis it was a hit yeah it was a big
movie people love gigantic film yeah and
he was waiting for the fences you know I
just
um I feel like
maybe just post post uh covid he's just
like been like I'm just gonna take a
bunch of stuff and he's taught he's
talked about this he did a bunch of like
movies that went right to streaming like
that Finch one on Apple TV and a few
others and I think that he was around
yeah I think he was one of those people
that was like oh maybe this is the new
thing and now we're all like nah this
isn't really anything
that they got a new Tom Hanks movie
actually that one Greyhound is pretty
good okay Finch I didn't love as much uh
you've seen this lawn Adam Halbert asks
I know be out of the ordinary but is it
possible to get a bow is afraid on his
trailer
uh I really enjoyed it but it would be a
tough it'd be a tough film for us if you
haven't seen it I don't even know what
we would joke about with you it's so
specific
very idiosyncratic but but I enjoyed it
a lot it's on vodena I mean we could do
like honest ariaster yeah I feel like
there's definitely step like Mom stuff
that runs through all of his food yeah
I'm not gonna watch something about the
Johnsons again though no no let's not
but just keep it to the features just
the features
yeah don't don't look that up do not
look that up on your work very troubling
early ariaster short up here it is
[Music]
that's it that's
it it's very it's very troubling but
it's it's in that in that ariaster way
where it's like it's horror and it's
comedy and it's cringe all at once oh
brisk 29 minutes yeah yeah all right I
couldn't have watched it for one minute
Great Performances very troubling okay
all right well throw that on the Queue
um all right back to where we were uh
benzite 10 how did you decide upon this
movie for the Australia a fan amongst
yourselves honestly it was like okay
well first of all we're in a serious
movie release drought uh that will
continue for just a few more weeks but
uh but I think we have some fun stuff in
there and it was like
uh Indiana Jones it was it's coming out
this week is to tie in with the dial of
Destiny on the mummy we've done
Uncharted like we could do Tomb Raider
one of those or something like that but
I wanted to watch Da Vinci Code yeah
it's also just a huge movie from the
last 20 years that we haven't done yeah
and that is a dwindling list at this
point oh the libraries yeah we've done
that before plundering yeah so anytime
we come up with like a big hit movie
that we haven't done we're like well
let's just do that when also we do the
directions yeah
um yeah and that that is I think the
sweet spot is like 96 to 2006 is like
that's when movies were still there were
still movies man they weren't all
franchise bait and uh and like people
like they were they were cultural
moments right and there were no Honest
Trailers yet so exactly there's a lot of
fertile ground uh we'll end with this is
what is Pat from Pat magana what is Paul
bettany's best role hmm let's see what
is what he's got I mean immediately the
first thing that pops into my brain is
uh matcher in in uh Master Commander oh
of course oh okay yeah I don't think
that was Jude Law I often get them
confused so that is betney he's great he
and Russell Crowe you really believe
that they've been friends for years and
they they have that easy back and forth
and uh so that that would be my pick
think mine's always going to be Knight's
tail and maybe it's because it was like
the first time that like he really like
stood out to me as an actor because he
was so funny and again The Chemistry
Between the cast was still great and
maybe the first time I realized he
wasn't Jude Law I'm also gonna I just I
I didn't remember this off the top of my
head but seeing it on IMDb uh gangster
number one have you guys ever seen that
uh it's a British gangster movie and it
it's it's two timelines you're following
Malcolm McDowell and he's this like one
of the top gangsters in London but then
you were also you're cutting back to
like prequel early career his rise where
he's played by Paul Bettany uh and it's
a really cool like weird messed up kind
of movie okay well I'll just pick him as
Vision I mean when he said what is grief
but love ever ever Everlasting I just
writing just you might as well have hung
it up I I really believe in the ship of
Theseus you made me believe it but you
know you bet master Commander is
definitely the best
all right I think that's it for for this
week because we gotta get hard uh to
work on uh our celebratory holiday
episode yeah July 4th July 4th and yet
it does include the Louvre
uh so we're gonna go we're gonna give
him a hearty F yeah to next week
you were doing so good and then uh
that's why they stick around oh and uh
Benjamin bromowitz uh why didn't we do
anything for the 500th episode we forgot
uh but but get ready for a special 500
and second or third episode next week on
Australia commenters we'll see you then
bye
-bye
Renaissance Man Forest
[Music]
laughs